التحقيق في انفجار مرفا بيروت يتعرقل اكثر
مع خلاف المشتعل بين القاضيين في النائب
العام التمييزي غسان عويدات وجهتهامات الى
القاضي طارق البيطار الذي يراس التحقيقات
وامر بالافراج عن جميع من جرى اعتقالهم
وساق اتهامات البيطار باغتصاب السلطه مع
اصدار قرار بمنعه من السفر برا وجوا وبحرا
بدورها قالت نقابه المحامين اللبنانيين ان
قرار النائب العام باطلاق صلاح الموقوفين
بقضيه المرفا غير قانوني مضيفه اي النقابه
انه على القضاه احترام قسمهم لتفادي
التحقيق الدولي في قضيه المرفرفاء وفيما
وصف بالطعنه بظهر القضاء نظم نواب مستقلون
ومعارضون واهالي ضحايا انفجار المرفى
اعتصاما امام قصر العدل ويتزاما ذلك مع
اجتماع لمجلس القضاء الاعلى لبحث التطورات
لا عم نشوف اليوم مش بس انقلاب على
الحقيقه والعداله اللي عملته اليوم انقلاب
على المؤسسات انقلاب على الديمقراطيه
انقلاب على الحريات ومحاوله فرد على
اللبنانيين نظام بوليسي جديد شغلتنا نحمي
القضاء من التدخلات السياسيه ومن قضاه
السلطه